[Music]
[Music]
ugly
it's a propeller
[Music]
hello
where did we oh yeah okay so we're in
this factory
uh we just defeated
the people with like
technology within them at
different places uh can we buy anything
oh yeah we've got the electricity so we
should be able to press this now too
ah yes yes
to hunger till next we meet
uh let's where's our little parts here
it is
okay i want to use it oh crap it ball
sacks
it's i don't have the oh
it's for this a certain shotgun shitty
oh wow i guess i'll try and
get that eventually
i'm not doing too great on ammo am i
maybe i can buy some ammo if it's just
looking window sharp away
please come again so should i press
these
oh bye
do i have to go up that ladder
i do believe i did not go up here
got a long way to go
uh
how the hell is this place so big it's
like the tardis
it didn't look this big from the outside
like are we are we underground
miranda thinks we're nothing but china
oh she doesn't care for us no
she's long lost
sorry i just interrupted him entirely
i must destroy her
i don't give a [ __ ] about your family
trauma
[Music]
hello
uh can i put anything down i've got this
one
nice
so they're mining for him they're like
these are the workers
his lovely work is
cheers i'll take that and just take that
nice nice nice
okay i'm gonna just look back what's
around here i know it's just another
zombie but
maybe if i can be real quiet
this is a cool shot
butt shot
oh hell yeah i'm glad i went down here
hello
okay what have we got where do we go
for following irini 92
oh how's the audio levels all sound good
do i need to turn me down do i need to
end the game now
if i can try and get my clothes to come
somewhere
come here boys
[Applause]
how many [ __ ] shots
oh you'll find your brother's blood
nice
beautiful what's this
i like pig i take
audio is bad all right nice thank you
everybody
crystal yes please
why i can't remember does ethan even
have
a flashlight because i feel like he
never uses it
but i do new
okay
oh what's through here yes please oh i
need an explosive
um can i just shoot
i got a pipe bomb i got a batman
i want the goodies give me all the
goodies
are they miming miming are they mining
for
crystals oh cause that was a lot
thank you
okay that's a lot of maps up there
what ever got here i got the wolf's beam
but
no i'm on for that thing i got rifle
[Music]
pump action oh yeah this one but i
haven't really got much for that either
whoa [ __ ] jesus christ in hell
no i'm not ready for this
no i've just started playing again i
don't really remember how to do
things with the stuff from the things
help
[Applause]
oh my god
oh [ __ ]
i feel like i don't have enough stuff
like anything
um
explosive rounds that could be useful
yeah let's do that
[ __ ]
oh god two of them
die just die
god there's so many of them what the
hell
[Music]
how am i gonna do this
oh my god
oh god ethan just run
[Applause]
[ __ ]
oh yeah
[Music]
i need to get some more ammo constantly
low on ammo i used to do so well for
ammo i know i just sucked
biggest frost that's the rest of them
i know probably not though
um yeah
yeah i should
i see you guys being really confused
about our red eyes um
i'm sorry my my lack of soul is
really showing today i tried to hide it
but i couldn't put my contacts on so i
was upset
i've got to stop
[Music]
i don't want to do that
i have to save all of this stuff
is there another way for me to
aha oh
i don't want to shoot
i wish i could just chuck my knife get
like a nunchuck
or something oh my god
i really hope i find the duke soon so i
can sell some stuff
uh
nothing good no okay
i'm gonna look in every nook and cranny
for some ammunition because it is badly
needed
right sold that enhancement sold at
jet attached a jet pack and head
stabilizers to a soul that
greatly improves mobility experiments
provide
oh no experiments prove limited flight
capabilities no long distance flight but
now possible to navigate
rugged terrain so that's enhancement so
that panzer
attached aluminium alloy shielding to
assault that
to protect chest reactor and exposed
flesh
experimentation proves he is invincible
against
regular firearms armor doesn't hold up
against strong blasts
uh so this is the ones that we just went
up against because
i think they were still quite resistant
to get strong blast but okay
sure um okay so that one's strong blast
and what's the other one
jet pack and head stabilizers
i don't think have we seen the jet pack
yeah i don't think so
okay crazy uh one second
i need to do something because one of my
lights is very annoying me it's
shouting it's shining brightly into my
face
and it's annoying me there you go oh
that's so much better
oh my soul has come back into my body
um jacob you can uh remove that if you
want to unless you think it's funny but
i don't know but back to the game
can't flip sure i'll take that a map
that's always nice a muddy boot
just one though
okay can i push this oh there's
something behind it got here
is that secret or is that the way to go
this this looks like it's the way to go
there's this secret isn't it i don't i
hate when you don't know which way is
the proper way because you don't want to
go the proper way you want to go the
secret way this way
yellow
am i supposed to be getting a glimpse
into the future here
oh no that's where i was just now
i'll take these thank you
okay let's have a look at the map
good that tells us nothing
foreign
[Music]
like
oh god this man i
can't oh
so silly
what's up there
looks like it's got a ladder to it can i
jump down
slide it all the way up there as well
no i didn't check the other side for the
secrets and things
yes please
oh
she'll start her ceremony with your rose
if that happens it's all over
for your kid and for the whole village
but don't worry i'll stop it
i'll use rose to kill miranda
poor papa you're the only one who
doesn't see your kid's power
take rose i'd like to see you try
i don't think it's the fact that he
can't see it's just that he doesn't care
because he loves rose
but who she is a sweet little bubba
not a super hero
weapon
and i just wish they were weapons
can make things now well a med kit thing
and i guess at least i do have um
some explosive rounds but that does make
me a bit scared about what's
become
i guess
there's more
more
not more of those big scary things
because i have hardly any ammunition i
can't do that
i was doing so well
can we jump down there why would i jump
down there i don't know let's do it
i jump down
this is cool
okay
[Applause]
what does this guy
oh thank you very much
i have got a lot of stuff to sell
okay i guess we go back and try the door
now
wait will this be like hey dude
will he come
i have to go and make molds don't i
before i can do this
surely
oh yeah because it's a
horsey key that i don't have
knew it'd be you shall i choose
something for you
i don't think i can do anything yeah i
gave all my stuff i'm skilled at all
sorts of weapons
till next week excuse me
uh so i need to go back to the bottom
floor
i believe to print out these
molds and then honestly i don't know
what to do with them
um well i guess i'll find
out
wait is it b3 where i need to go i just
press b4
is it before no i think it i don't know
hey mixerlight uh where am i i just got
um let me show you
oh where the bloody hell is it a key
mold
and another mold a bowl mold
and now i am going to make these molds
oh there's a lot of red places
where is that over here
can you go back down there see what i
missed
no probably not
oh how the hell have i not been here
i'll make the little ball with the ball
mold that'd be cool
that was weird did you hear that
okay is that it is that all i can pick
up in here
so i can pick up in here apart from the
ball thing
yes okay well it's better than nothing
i will take it i'll be
happy about it
i can't believe i'd never had gone in
there yet
so is this the right place i'm going in
the workplace is this right now
it's dark
is this where i go to
get the molds
oh this is the downside to not playing
for a long time i forget the things
why is it so dark
and the music is so dramatic
yeah i think this is the place
oh
you come here buddy
i love my shotgun i love it more than
life i love a shotgun
because it takes away life from my
enemies
trust me when i say uh
where do i go to get my molds again
because i thought i've got because i
haven't played this game
forever
[Music]
hello
i said
[Music]
oh
okay before we continue on oh no
i was gonna mix more of these because
they were doing us some very good
service
um okay then
oh there is a lockpick box over there
oh and there's heisenberg's quarters so
if we get this key
then perhaps what's over here is switch
this is exciting there's things that we
haven't fully explored yet let's go up
here
i know i'm i'm gonna go back to that box
don't worry
have a feeling where it's supposed to go
this way
excuse me where are these
people hopefully down there
oh is that for the is that magnum
oh i see them they're all ready to jump
out again
yeah it was
uh okay let's do the key all so we're
gonna get the key
with chemo and then we're gonna get the
ball
with the bomber
so much blood on the floor
[Music]
hello
trust me
when i get back gonna be fun
okay i'm going to be ready for this
let's move on
uh
uh
[Applause]
is
that goes on to my other mechanical
piece surely
where are all the stuff here
yes can i use it
oh look at that fan piece of
mechanic splicing
ice breaks hammer a giant hammer made
from machine parts
it's too heavy to use ethan
why are you not lifting bro
you got to get on heisenberg's game
it's fine ethan loves his guns
is there anything to read in this room
hello right now i
may go on back
what is this though up here i'm going to
go to the switch
because it's got a big exclamation mark
and
it's enticing me please up here
i am aware there might be some bad
person on the other side of this door
though
that's okay i do have one of these
oh there's like two of them
um but there's got to be good stuff here
it's an optional area there's got to be
good stuff here
and stuff let me pick up and hear about
me oh
thank y'all very nice very nice
can i oh [ __ ]
there's not just two there is like a
whole bunch and i
really hope they don't wake up
oh that faces are so creepy
[Music]
he's not even lying down his legs are
levitating
they're so magic oh my god there's more
over here i'm freaking out
ethan just crawling on the floor holding
his mind
for dear life like protect me by protect
me
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay calm down
oh my god that's not calm
[Applause]
these ones with the arms they're never
nice at least i know these guys aren't
waking up because if they were gonna
wake up they definitely would have woken
up from that
okay i know you guys are fine now we're
all friends here can i look at you now
okay that is creepy as
oh that's so crazy he's just oh
peel the eyes wide open look at that
nice
anyway
oh give me these things my wolf's name i
never use it revitalization surgery
this is my 18th attempt
the subject is oscar the stable boy 20
years old
he fell down the well while drunk body
is in good condition
just incision complete now to remove the
heart
and vital organs and implant the control
device
excellent cado has begun adhering to the
nervous system
it's progressing even faster than before
seems upping the ratio of meta album in
the artificial blood was the right
choice
now to pass a current through the brain
stem using 6
600 volts come on
it has to work this time
yes yes
wonderful my creation
ending recording yeah i'm glad he went
here and checked it out that was super
cool
it's a nice bit of world building as
well
what's my favorite resident evil game
today i mean
i'm biased because i i didn't really
play the old ones
i watched my friends play them so
resident evil 7
okay fingers crossed nothing's going to
jump out of me
i just went this way we just need to go
back to
but i don't i don't think so i don't
think so i can hear something this is
not good
can i make any explosives oh
[ __ ] no
that's a flashbang i don't want a
flashbang i want explosives
fine a flashbang will do
[ __ ] huge name
where is this thing even
oh my god i'm scared
why do i have any
are you still like shocked goodbye
how am i supposed to defeat you
what's me
wait i bought i got something let me
attach it to you
you're stupid
oh he's a scary one
have we found is a visible barrier so we
can use this to our advantage
love spain
this gun's useless oh my [ __ ] god
i thought i found his invisible barrier
no
i have no explosives
there are no red lights on this dude
and i just used all my wolf spain
ammo that's all sad but yeah he's like
covered in
uh
i don't i literally don't know where to
shoot him
unless it's on the back of his head
yeah i'm out of mind i'm out of
everything everything explosive
which is what he doesn't like right
there is apparently something in here
though that i haven't gotten
so let's let's have a look there
look for whatever i haven't got
hopefully we'll find all of mine just
like sitting on the floor and it'll be
really nice
i'll be like thanks game you knew i
needed it
huh oh
damn it there's stuff out here as well
apparently
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i just wanted to run
past you
okay maybe i can get around
uh so anyway i can get back to duke
what the [ __ ]
okay
where's the maybe you have to wait since
like
where i am where is this hill
where is
explosives please
oh thank [ __ ] for this right
hopefully i can buy some explosives
i don't think i can though
oh good i was just thinking of ways to
pass the time
i'm skilled everyone's like use
explosives i'm like i know
i have none explosive okay
no explosive ammo oh and we have the
ball so
good day then
shall i choose something for you i could
sell things as well
oh and heisenberg's hammer
pay me nobody
i want i just need metal scrap that's
what i need
i can make some explosive rounds
well at least i've got two pipe bombs
now i've got mine
if i say so myself
thanks duke your dude
now you are just a lowly one without
no it fell down the
oh to stairs doors i was in the middle
of something there
i actually didn't expect her to come out
here
no i just want to
hello pretty fancy armor dude
a great way to fight
it's like being in a toxic relationship
he leaves i chase after him he comes
back again
yes finally get
screw you we're done here
now let's do the ball oh good i was just
thinking of ways to pass the time
okay i look forward to seeing the fruits
of your exploration cheers to you
let's go do the ball and then
we can go and progress at the top level
sassy yeah it's not often i guess sassy
isn't it
enjoy it while you count or not i don't
know
oh no what
this one's really annoying i wish you
could
oh my god this changes everything
i didn't know you could do that
okay
how we only just found out this
okay careful careful
easy does it easy yes
oh oh um oh oh stop
let's go back
this is quite an intricate one not like
the other ones
oh oh okay
oh [ __ ]
okay well at least we've solved the
first problem
okay and then back out
all the way down to the bottom don't get
caught in there
because i thought i had to go in there
but i don't and oh my god the
train's not there okay where do you go
when the train is there oh god i don't
know i don't know but i'm going in now
i don't know where to go when the train
is there when the train is there i don't
know where
oh i'm going down here instead
and i go into the magic tunnel
oh oh my god
that was freaking ridiculous thank you
do you have to make such weird noises if
it's just looking window sharp away
okay
um let's go back up here
oh okay sweet i will try to do that
thanks mixer like for let me know
if you see a hanging body in the
conveyor belt shoot it
simple as that
oh that's why you do that because you
chop ash on yourself
uh can i shoot them on the conveyor
belts up here
i think i'm too far away up here let's
do it from down there
or the middle one
oh my gosh that was a wooden donkey
thing
oh nothing happened
i'm not wasting any more ammo
oh [ __ ] no i missed the donkey
it's not donkeys it's like a goat why
why do i call it a donkey
we're gonna be here forever
oh
maybe i have to shoot it
it's already gone
hey useless mug don't worry i'm
literally just trying to shoot
a freaking goat on a
on a piece of the elevator so there's
the spoilers right now
but no worries if you want to leave i
totally understand right so let's
oh i've got it
thought it was going to take me so much
longer than that
i'm so proud of myself he's got garlic
in here is that because
he was afraid of um
lady d perhaps but he knows that she's
gone now right so
why has he kept that there interesting
i've seen videos pop up on my youtube
saying the origins of duke and i'm
definitely going to watch them once i'm
done because i'm interested to know
about
why is he here like whose side is he on
is even on a side how does he just get
everywhere i want to know more about him
very intrigued
um i might call it a night i'm just
gonna have a little look
in here first though
very elaborate door
you really are a tough one
but i'm tired of chitchat time to die
uh you can hear it can't you
someone's waiting for you
sturm use the cheap turbo prop oh
for fork seek it's the dude from the
beginning of when i came in here
but he's impossible to control all he
does is charge
too much power output from the reactor
completely invincible
head on but the dumbass managed to chop
his own damn
arms off on the propeller also
issues with overheating from running for
long periods of time
good to know a complete failure
but the most scariest one in my opinion
so there's that too
hmm
okay
i don't have time for this [ __ ] out
of my way
wait
okay that worked that way
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
why did you stop that time hello sir
oh there you are hello
is
oh my god oh my god
i'm definitely gonna
just keep
whoa
[Music]
definitely
[Music]
oh
oh how the [ __ ] oh my god i'm still
alive
i don't know how
ethan get your guns out what the [ __ ] is
happening
okay
that's a big
oh gosh i really need to make some stuff
we'll find some stuff
have some stuff
oh
hello this is my favorite place to be
what
no no
well
are you done yet quite done
oh [ __ ]
i do not know how
come on ethan just crafted
okay
oh hello i'm trying to get behind
him
he turn around for me buddy
where are you now
i gotta like aim further down
uh
enough
oh my god
oh
it is
there you go
come here
please slow down take it easy
i wish there was more things there's
gonna be some stuff in here to pick up
somewhere
i'm just hugging somebody oh god
oh god i'm still alive how is this
possible
what is the what is the world literally
don't know
uh
oh
being inspired
get behind him when he does that
whoa
oh that was good
now stay down is it down
did the game was the game designed that
you couldn't lose that battle because i
really should have died multiple times
and i didn't
and i'm very confused
but i'm happy
oh my god yeah i actually yeah i don't
know how oh
cool i've got some shotgun shells i
think it's for this one though
no was that not why i picked up okay i
got some sort of shells
anything else pick up very immediately
oh schneider sorry again
middle button is shoot
oddly enough
apparently the chat had lots of
hilarious comments
i don't know what those comments were i
didn't see i was too busy
nourishing my sore thumb
yeah i'm actually very proud of myself
well done
well done me good running good running
good running ethan
good running and uh coming back from
near death that was
very that was very good
miranda is abominable her deceit knows
no bounds
we're merely a bunch of failed caddo
experiments to her
i was just lucky i had more affinity to
the staff than the other poor schmucks
in the village
so she still calls me her son also he
he was just like another villager
because lady d
wasn't was she was she i don't know
what a joke i'll never forgive her for
what she did to me
that crazy [ __ ] has never been right in
the head she can't see a difference
between experiment
and family miranda didn't just change my
body
she took my dignity if i don't kill her
then my life will never be my own
still she may be crazy
but she's also powerful she can turn in
she can turn it into anyone using the
mega my seat
the trick is that rat rose
if i can access her power then maybe
okay so we know that
miranda could literally be anything
anything or anyone
she well anyone do we think that she
might be that old lady that we saw at
the beginning of the game or
or no maybe not
maybe not speaking of the kid's dad
ethan has a pretty interesting body
himself
maybe i could get him to help me out
yeah you did try that but
it didn't really work did it oh cigar i
know someone who would like
that don't we i bet he played top
dollar for another cigar so you can just
keep
pouring the ash all over himself he has
a thing for that
is this the way to go next yeah so i'm
gonna go into this
i can hear it there you are
yeah so gaming with malachi lady d was
not local
she was royalty from somewhere else
heisenberg was probably more recent
acquisition
this makes more sense and this makes
more sense obviously why he
is against miranda and even though part
of
the family doesn't really want to be
part of the family
so yeah makes perfect sense
nice i can probably make some explosives
with that
can i get into any of these rooms
[Music]
yes
[Music]
no
oh that was cool did you see that
you're not like
is it i think so
really nothing for me to pick up here no
isn't it
you're persistent but i've got a
rebellion
so stay out of my life
change
should have seen that coming really
shouldn't i
that bastard
again
i'm guessing there will be no fish down
here
huh
i told you to leave it alone ethan
you are in the way what do you care
chris
you killed my wife you son of a [ __ ]
you think i killed mia
that wasn't her it was miranda
what oh
she changed her appearance and pretended
to be mia
seems she also survived being shot so
now i'm here to finish the job
[ __ ] why don't you [ __ ] tell me
right away
because i knew you would want to be
involved and this job is hard enough
without civilians getting in the way
why huss chris
what the hell is going on
all right ethan all right
i guess i owe you an explanation
hand me that wrench
so where's the real mia then
long story short miranda's [ __ ]
insane
in this village all these monsters and
freaks
this is her life's work some sort of
crazy experiment with the mold
like louisiana god damn it
all this time i thought i could save my
family
i can't escape from here i can't do
anything
that might not be true
take a look at this my men sent those
pictures a few minutes ago
miranda keep looking
what is that rose
holy [ __ ] we gotta go relax my men are
monitoring the situation
but they have my daughter you don't get
anything in pieces you don't stand a
chance against miranda by yourself
you should just see me against some
propeller dude
i will stay down here and finish
planting explosives you take that
elevator i'll meet you topside
i promise you we will get your daughter
back together
damn straight and when i find miranda
she's a dead woman
he's like yeah all right whatever you
take this
and do me a favor try to stay under the
radar
i can't turn back now can i play with
this
because it is
uh is there anything i can steal from
you while i'm here oh yes i'll take this
yes i i need to have that i know but
maybe i'll just wait oh wait
no fish don't think fish would uh
survive here
to be honest
i can save here okay well i guess this
would be my save point then
to hound wolf squad the sweep
of the factory is complete no proof of
any connection with the organization
guess this just wasn't our lucky day i
did manage to get my hands on a number
of documents disclosing some of
miranda's experiments
which supports our previous theories
what's that noise oh it's it's from
within the game i thought that it was
hailing outside
i don't know if you can hear that uh
anyway
uh i did manage to get my hands on a
number of documents disclosing some of
my own experiments which supported
the series she seems to have infected
herself with the mutant mesit
which has granted a number of abilities
including
mimicry that sounds like a bloody
pokemon move
mimicry uh miranda you use mirrorcry
she can control herself and transform
herself to
like anyone or anything so she is a
mimic
she disguised herself as mia and
infiltrated the winters
as home her objective was clearly to
kidnap rose
maybe she thought she could control
royals easier if she looked like her mum
i mean yeah understandable what did she
do with mia
when she we attacked it put a little
damper on her plans so she mimicked a
corpse
she then revived herself oh
she then revived herself in the
transport truck
killed everyone on board and took off
with rose
things didn't go the way she had
originally planned but in the end
she still got what she wanted until now
it's time to rendezvous and blow this
place sky high
this might not this might turn into a
fight with heisenberg
but i think i found some useful stuff he
left one of his little toys lying around
and it's even made from a metal
polymer composite which he can't control
oh so he can control metal
well no he can control machinery but not
certain types of metal
okay cool and he's going to use
his own machine against it
where did chris go in here
[Music]
i guess
can i make anything while i'm at it yeah
let's make another one i need to
[Music]
explosive or shotgun wallets
okay that is where i will
leave off for today thank you
for spending the evening with me
[Music]
uh i will be back next week the same
time as usual i will be back
[Music]
thursday 8 30 pm bst have a lovely day
evening
um bye
you